en 47 ans de carrière vous avez suivi
quelques 250 affaires plaider du côté
des partis civils dans les procès des
tueurs en série Francis haul Michel
Fourniret ou encore Pierre Bodin mais
diriez-vous que la grande affaire de
votre vie reste celle de Christine et
Jean-Marie Villemin que vous accompagnez
depuis 1985 oui certainement oui
effectivement j'ai tissé avec Christine
Jean-Marie qui sont des gens merveilleux
j'ai tissé des relations de confiance
d'abord et d'amitié on se voit encore
régulièrement mais souvent en contact
téléphonique Jean-Marie vous présente
comme son frère oui grand frère j'étais
très très heureux de la très très belle
postface elle a bien voulu rédiger dans
mon livre et donc et Christine et
Jean-Marie sont des gens merveilleux ils
sont merveilleux de gentillesse dualité
d'attention Grégory est folle à tout
point de vue c'est de loin le fait
divers le plus retentissant de la
seconde moitié du 20e siècle celui qui a
fait couler au moins autant d'encre que
la Valogne suscissait le plus grand
nombre de dérapages et de bavure aussi
bien journalistique que judiciaire
article livre documentaire on a par
ailleurs tout lu tout entendu jusqu'à la
lit sur cette affaire du plus sérieux au
plus fantaisiste en passant par le plus
sordide le meurtre du petit Grégory
c'est l'affaire avec un grand A elle
résume à elle toute seule toutes les
souffrances humaines et toutes les
dérives
celui à vrai on a vu des choses
écoeurantes et qu'on fait avec moi et
que rentre dans ce dossier et puis je
voudrais quand même rappeler que
complètement désespéré par l'inertie de
l'institution judiciaire et du monde
notamment du monde de l'instruction de
juge d'instruction que je vise sans
citer et puis également
ulcéré par les débordements de certains
médias qui ont eu un comportement
inacceptable et bien Jean-Marie Villemin
a malheureusement commis les réparable
il a tué Bernard Laroche comme vous le
savez je ne peux évidemment pas en tant
qu'être humain et en tant qu'avocat je
ne peux pas cautionner ce crime sur la
personne de Bernard Laroche mais je
comprends Jean-Marie je comprends et par
ailleurs par la suite quelques mois plus
tard lorsque Christine est renvoyé fin
1986 oui fin 1986 par devant la cour des
6 de Nancy pour assassinat sur la
personne de son petit Grégory c'est là
elle est désespérée elle fait une
tentative de suicide elle me laisse une
lettre d'adieu qui est l'échéance
mais mais vraiment on a vécu alors Dieu
soit loué la Cour de cassation début 87
à rectifier le tir en cassant cet arrêt
scandaleux de Nancy et en délocalisant
le dossier tout ça vous le savez mais on
a vécu mes collègues et moi mes
confrères et moi des moments de de
désespoir et maman de désespoir
également quand vous lisez l'article
très accusatoire sublime forcément
sublime de Marguerite Duras qui lui a
d'ailleurs valu à son tour un temps de
boue comment cela de l'autre côté sur le
banc des accusés comment l'avez-vous
vécu mais très très mal très très mal le
alors le juge Lambert pour ne pas le
citer n'est-ce pas été absolument
subjugué par Marguerite Duras alors ce
petit juge s'imaginait avoir la capacité
de faire une carrière littéraire et leur
devoir la grande marguerite venir à
Épinal mais enfin si c'est pour lui
c'était la potée n'est-ce pas voilà mais
cet article était écoeurant il était bas
il était il était absolument nul et
alors Christine Villemin avec son bon
sens habituel a fait cette réflexion qui
qui nous a beaucoup amusé mes collègues
et moi elle a dit mais enfin elle est un
peu toquée celle-là
faut-il le préciser qui a été le premier
juge d'instruction de cette affaire
alors vous vous connaissez le dossier
dans ces moindres recoins pourquoi cette
affaire facite-t-elle le temps qu'est-ce
qu'elle dit de nous
de choses d'abord c'était le meurtre
d'un enfant un enfant c'est qui avait ce
qu'il y a de plus sacré je le crois dans
notre société et puis il y avait une
dose de mystère il y avait des
rebondissements il y avait aussi un côté
tout à fait mal simple à savoir que
certains esprits ont imaginé cette
théorie
saugrenue extravagante de la culpabilité
de la mère et pour certaines personnes
une mère qui serait dénaturée qui serait
une espèce de sorcière une hypocrite
mais mais ça c'est formidable
est trop jolie finalement il est évident
que tout cela ça crée des des jalousies
des envies et puis alors il y a chez
l'être humain c'est pas très joli mais
il y a ce cet attirance morbide pour ce
qui est malsain et alors tous ces
ingrédients ont fait que plus la
rapacité la rapacité de certains organes
de presse et bien tout cela
effectivement
pas fait gonfler démesurément
artificiellement et d'une façon odieuse
se triste ce triste
assassinataire quand on voit tel
magistrat inculpé d'assassinat vous
parlez du juge Lambert une mère déjà
crucifiée par la mort de son fils ou tel
autre reconnaître l'innocence de cette
même mère mais appuyer son renvoi devant
les assises pour complaire l'opinion
parce que c'est ça qui s'est passé
croisons encore en la justice de son
pays je vous avoue très sincèrement
qu'un certain jour j'ai désespéré de la
de la justice et comme vous le dites à
l'instant
le l'arrêt de Nancy de 1986 est rendue
Christine Villemer envoyé aux assises je
rencontre l'un des magistrats composants
la chambre d'accusation comme ça qu'on
disait à l'époque de la cour d'appel de
Nancy il me dit ceci j'ouvre les
guillemets je cite ne vous en faites pas
nous avons dû vu l'opinion publique
renvoyée aux assises mais si j'étais
juré Jacky te Ray non mais c'est
absolument inouï c'est une négation
absolue totale de la justice c'est
odieux et je suis encore je ferais bien
qu'en alignation aujourd'hui en vous
racontant tout cela alors rendez-vous eu
le sentiment à l'époque de défendre une
martyre en la personne de Christine
villeminisée elle a intensément souffert
de même que Jean-Marie et là vous savez
je me souviens de cette époque c'était
en début juillet 1995
Christine était incarcéré à Metz que le
suite à la décision aberrante de du juge
Lambert et Jean-Marie de son côté était
incarcéré à Nancy pour avoir assassiné
malheureusement Bernard Laroche et alors
lorsque mais quand fallait moi nous
allions voir Christine ah mais est-ce
que le elle nous disait mais partez
rapidement allez voir Jean-Marie dans sa
prison de Nancy et lorsque nous allions
voir Jean-Marie à Nancy il nous tenait
le même discours aller voir Christine et
alors je rappelle aussi que la
malheureuse Christine a fait une grève
de la faim pendant sa détention pour
protester je rappelle aussi qu'elle
était enceinte elle attendait son petit
garçon qui devait naître
en septembre 1985 cette dame cette femme
cette jeune femme cette cette maman
cette victime d'un assassinat a été
traitée par notre justice à l'époque
d'une façon absolument scandaleuse
scandaleuse odieux un juge dilettante à
côté de ses pompes et manipuler par les
médias une instruction chaotique
lacunaire truffée d'irrégularité de
procédure d'erreur grossière et de
manquements tragiques une guéguerre
aussi entre gendarme et policiers trois
décennies de cafouillage et de fausses
pistes est-ce que pareil naufrage
judiciaire serait encore possible
aujourd'hui
je pense que malheureusement oui mais
les chances que cela se reproduise sont
quand même réduites sont quand même
réduites alors pour quelles raisons je
crois que d'abord on a fait des progrès
dans la méthodologie on sait quand même
mieux gérer un dossier criminel la
police technique est scientifique a fait
également des progrès sensationnels
depuis 25 ou 30 ans grosso modo et
toutes ces possibilités scientifiques
n'existaient malheureusement pas à
l'époque en 1984 lorsque Grégory est
assassiné par ailleurs on a aussi je
crois des une presse qui me semble à
l'heure actuelle plus responsable qui a
pris conscience très nettement de la
nécessité impérieuse et absolue de
respecter la présomption d'innocence je
trouve je trouve qu'il y a des progrès
je ne suis pas en train de de
dresserique mais je pense qu'il y a des
progrès dont je pense que le dérapage
pourrait encore malheureusement exister
mais les risques sont heureusement je
crois je l'espère réduit près de 40 ans
après l'effet est-il possible de
rattraper ses erreurs par ailleurs
dommageables à l'éclosion de la vérité
si nous avons beaucoup de chance oui
c'est-à-dire ce qui est tout à fait vous
croyez toujours en la résolution de
cette affaire aujourd'hui j'y crois
parce que j'ai naturel optimisme
peut-être et puis parce que c'est ce qui
est tout à fait frustrant dans ce
dossier nous savons les magistrats mais
confrères et moi-même nous savons qui a
fait quoi comment pourquoi nous le
savons ça veut dire ça veut dire que
depuis le temps vous savez vous
connaissez l'identité du ou des
coupables je réponds oui je pourrais
vous dire un tel a fait ceci un tel a
fait cela mais il est évident entre le
savoir et le démontrer c'est le jour et
la nuit la fin n'est toujours pas résolu
les coupables toujours pas condamnés
alors l'affaire est toujours en cours à
Dijon vous avez bien raison le souligner
nous attendons actuellement nous avons à
Dijon le président énergie qui s'appelle
Dominique Bros qui se démène et fait de
son mieux j'espère que les expertises
qui sont actuellement cours de
réalisation notamment au plan génétique
pourront nous permettre d'avancer il
nous faut un peu de chance pour qu'il en
soit ainsi mais je crois je crois
j'espère qu'avec du temps de la patience
de la persévérance de l'opini à traiter
je crois que nous pouvons y arriver et
puis alors j'ai encore un autre espoir
qui est le suivant vous savez l'arrêt de
de la chambre de Dijon de février 1993
indique que il y a des gens qui savent
mais qui gardent le silence qui ne
veulent pas parler et aussi longtemps
que ces gens-là ne s'expriment pas le
dossier pourrait continuer à s'enliser
je crois maintenant nous sommes en 2022
il se pourrait que les langues viennent
à se délier il se pourrait que les
obstacles qui se dressaient devant les
gens pour les empêcher de parler ils
viennent à disparaître à s'amenuiser
c'est aussi l'espoir que je formule
se fait divers à semer la mort le petit
Grégory bien évidemment suivi de Bernard
Laroche vous disiez tuer par balle le
juge Lambert suicidé son successeur qui
a laissé sa santé quel répercussions ont
talus sur vous Thierry
personnellement et bien je dirais que
j'ai une chance extraordinaire
j'ai
conjoint qui me soutient depuis toujours
qui est un appui à Rock depuis bientôt
50 ans j'ai des enfants adorables j'ai
des petits enfants
j'ai j'avais devant moi Christie et
Jean-Marie qui sont des gens merveilleux
j'avais envie de vraiment de faire de
mon mieux de donner le meilleur de
moi-même
je travaillais avec des confrères de
grande qualité et je veux évoquer la
mémoire notamment de Henri Garraud qui
est décédé aujourd'hui comme vous le
savez qui était un monsieur et aux côtés
de ce grand confrère et ayant toutes ces
comment dirais-je tous ces réconforts
autour de moi qui m'entourent et bien
j'ai tenu le choc j'ai tenu le choc mais
il y a eu des jours effectivement de
lassitude de fatigue de découragement
cette affaire vous touche encore au cœur
vous avez été mis au larmes en même
temps elle vous a projeté à l'insulte
votre plein gré sur le devant de la
scène judiciaire en 47 ans d'exercices
vous avez écumé toutes les cours
d'assises de l'Est de la France 250
procès criminels dont ceux de Michel
Fourniret ou Francis Hollande on le
disait où vous représentiez les victimes
être du côté des participes plutôt que
du côté des accusés dans ces dossiers
c'est un choix où le fruit du hasard non
c'est un choix je dirais premièrement
comme
observation préliminaire je dirais que
pour un avocat pénaliste je crois qu'il
est indispensable de plaider tantôt pour
l'accusé et tantôt pour la victime
partie civile pourquoi parce que cette
comment dirais-je cette situation doit
permettre à l'avocat de garder son
équilibre ça pondération de ne pas
tomber dans l'excès parce qu'un excès
est absolument nocif dans un débat
judiciaire qui se veut serein dans les
dossiers que vous citez effectivement
j'étais du côté des victimes parce que
j'étais sensible d'avoir mon choisi ces
personnes m'ont choisi et puis j'ai été
sensible à la détresse de ces malheureux
rendez-vous compte l'affaire fournirait
bah c'est c'est l'erreur absolue Michel
Fourniret Monique Olivier qui ont quand
même
occasionnés sur 20 ans sur 20 ans
d'activités criminelles la mort de 10-12
ou davantage de personnes des enfants
et certains dossiers donc été vraiment
intolérables insupportables et je me
sentais du côté des victimes dans quel
état sort-on de ces procès j'imagine que
se frotter d'aussi près à l'incarnation
du mal ça n'est pas anodin surtout pour
un croyant parce que vous êtes croyant
je suis croyant je suis pratiquant très
modérée très moyen enfin je des
convictions profondes croyez au mal
absolu en tant qu'avocat alors je me
pose des questions il y a chez l'être
humain c'est tellement ambivalent cette
j'ai dit un jour que que l'être humain
est parfois parfois enthousiasmant et
parfois horriblement désespérant il y a
en nous l'ambivalence pardon du bien du
mal c'est c'est très c'est très
troublant et je crois que mais vous
incitez sur le fait que l'auteur d'un
crime abjecte n'est pas forcément
lui-même objects oui il faut distinguer
ça peut sembler paradoxal mais j'ai dit
aussi que l'auteur d'un crime grave peut
avoir représenter cependant une moralité
qui n'a rien de malsain et alors dans
mon livre je donne l'exemple qui qui m'a
frappé j'y pense encore aujourd'hui je
défendais il y a 25 ou 30 ans je ne sais
plus à un jeune homme il avait 22 23 ans
il s'appelait Guillaume et il avait
poignardé avec beaucoup de sauvagerie
son grand-père et sa grand-mère vous
allez me dire c'est abominable ça n'a
pas de nom il faut le il faut l'expédier
Aubagne voilà vous pouvez me dire cela
et ce ce Guillaume en réalité
fournissait des explications sur le
pourquoi de son action alors je vais pas
rentrer dans les détails ce serait
beaucoup trop long là sur sa psychologie
et lors du procès j'ai été vraiment
beaucoup aidé
par le directeur d'enquête qui était un
gendarme très consciencieux c'était le
lieutenant race si je me souviens bien
qui est venu dire et bien que
visiblement pendant le temps de sa garde
à vue Guillaume était repentant il
réalisait la gravité de ce qu'il avait
fait il était soulagé d'avoir dit la
totale et entière vérité il n'a jamais
cherché à biaiser par devant la justice
et
il comme un dirige il était il
présentait la moralité d'un garçon
défaillant mais ayant une moralité saine
et j'ai obtenu dans les années qui ont
suivi ce procès j'ai obtenu sa
réhabilitation et je peux vous dire que
il est maintenant il est commerçant il
est marié il est père de famille il n'a
plus jamais fait parler de lui donc ça
ça démontre bien qu'effectivement même
si on commet un acte grave ça ne veut
pas dire pour autant qu'on est perdu
moralement parlant ou sociétalement
parlant
vous racontez éprouver de la sympathie
pour l'auteur d'un crime de la sympathie
ou de la compassion
sympathique compassion bah écouter tout
à l'heure on parlait de Jean-Marie
villemain ben voilà encore Jean-Marie
Villemin qui commet un assassine et je
disais que je ne peux évidemment pas
cautionner mais je comprends il n'en
obstant la gravité d'un acte
d'assassinat j'ai pour Jean-Marie la
plus vive
affection je dis bien affection amitié
c'est un garçon bien c'est un homme bien
il est maintenant père de famille à
trois grands enfants qui ont d'ailleurs
fort bien réussi dans la vie il est
toujours en couple avec Christine c'est
un couple aimant et alors lorsque
parfois je les vois dans des activités
privées ils sont là comme des
tourtereaux la main dans la main ben moi
je suis un peu fleur bleue je suis je
suis ému en voyant cela tiens le respect
de l'accusé et chez vous non négociable
d'ailleurs votre on était intellectuel
détonne un peu dans les prétois vous
n'avez d'ailleurs pas hésité à plaider
selon votre conscience dans le procès de
Francis Heaulme convaincu de l'innocence
de pratique Dils vous êtes allé jusqu'à
le défendre contre la vie de vos clients
ils auraient pu vous récuser ils vous
ont laissé faire c'est un cadre de
figure et de conscience pour le moins
inédit
alors en deux mots nous parlons du crime
de Montigny-lès-Metz 1986 deux enfants
assassinés d'une façon bestiale un petit
jeune homme de 16 ans qui s'appelle
Patrick dilse qui un mois après le crime
passe des aveux complets ces aveux
réitérer devant le juge d'instruction
sont rapidement rétractées la justice ne
veut rien entendre ça n'intéresse pas la
justice cette rétractation de ce petit
jeune homme de 16 ans auditionné en
garde à vue à l'époque sans aucun avocat
il livrait comme un dirige au bon
vouloir de du commissaire de police qui
soit dit en passant était un monsieur
avec lequel j'irai pas dîner bon voilà
j'en dis pas plus bien voilà donc le
malheureux deals est condamné à très
très lourdement perpétuité
et il purge 15 ans dans les conditions
très très éprouvantes et alors grâce à
Dieu grâce ou à la Providence le dossier
redémarre parce qu'il y a un gendarme
qui s'appelle abdgraal qui enquête sur
les crimes de Francis Holmes et ce
gendarme perspicace acquiert la
conviction que Holmes pourrait être
éventuellement l'auteur du crime de
Montigny-lès-Metz et partant et bien
évidemment deal serait aussi innocent
que vous et moi bien et je suis l'avocat
de l'un des parents de l'un des deux
enfants assassinés le petit Alexandre
voilà et les parents ont vécu les procès
ils ont vécu les aveux de deals ils ont
trouvé ces aveux très convaincants et
lorsque Francis Holmes comparait dans le
box des accusés à Metz les parents
finalement s'intéressent peu à ce procès
ils imaginent que le vrai coupable c'est
deals qui dans l'interval a été acquitté
à Lyon en 2002 et ils sont convaincus
que finalement
Francis Holmes pour Tristan individu
qu'ils soient et cependant et cependant
un bouc émissaire dans l'affaire ou un
faux coupable dans l'affaire de
Montigny-lès-Metz moi je leur dis ce
procès va durer trois semaines à moi il
faut suivre ce procès de A jusqu'à Z et
alors seulement vous avez le droit de
vous forger une conviction mais ce
discours raisonnable que je tiens ne les
convain qu'à moitié ils traînent des
pieds et finalement peu de temps avant
la plénerie je leur dis ben voilà moi je
vais plaider selon ma conscience tout en
sachant donc je vais effectivement
demander à la Cour de retenir la
culpabilité de Francis Holmes tout en
sachant que les propos que je tiens ne
vous conviennent pas alors c'est pas
compliqué ou bien vous me dessaisissez
du dossier je fais ma valise je m'en
vais je rentre à la maison ou bien vous
me laissez plaider selon ma conscience
mais à ce moment là sachez que les
propos que je vais tenir pourront vous
faire grimacer bon voilà alors nous
avons retenu l'option numéro 2 j'ai
plaidé et j'écoute voilà c'est plutôt
inédit c'est très très inconfortable et
très finalement très très déroutant
cette situation pour un point d'avocat
et donc Metz condamne effectivement OLM
donc réclusion Crimée à la pervidité
plus période de sûreté il fait appel
confirmation devant la cour d'appel de
Versailles oui et rejet du pouvoir par
la Cour de cassation
alors bilan je crois que les parents
sont toujours
ancrés dans leur conviction de la
culpabilité de deals ils sont je crois
toujours possédés par l'idée selon
laquelle
Francis Holmes est un innocent condamné
injustement et moi je vous le dis je le
dis avec une certaine émotion je suis
peiné parce que ces personnes les
parents que j'aimais bien que je
défendais au mieux je n'ai pas réussi à
les convaincre j'étais certainement très
peu convaincant et au jour d'aujourd'hui
ça me pèse encore est-ce que vous pensez
pour le droit pour la recherche de la
vérité parce que votre confrère hervait
été mis aime à répéter complète pour le
droit non pour la morale or dans La
Poste face de votre livre Jean-Marie
Villemin écrit à propos de vous Thierry
pense que l'application trouve
formaliste de la procédure pénale peut
parfois malheureusement empêcher
l'éclosion de la vérité ce qui est
inacceptable d'un point de vue moral
cette primauté de la morale pour un
avocat c'est singulier non je pense que
il faut tenir compte évidemment des
règles juridiques pour autant qu'elles
ne bouscule pas la morale il faut tenir
compte évidemment de la matérialité des
faits il faut bien les analyser les
replacer dans leur contexte etc et puis
il faut tenir compte encore et surtout
de la personnalité de l'auteur sont
psychisme sa psychologie voilà je crois
les trois ingrédients le droit les fêtes
et la personnalité et c'est en me basant
sur ces trois ingrédients que je
conçois que je que je pompe n'est-ce pas
mes plaidoiries et alors je vais encore
insister vous donner l'occasion insister
sur une idée qui m'est chère c'est que
l'avocat doit être totalement
indépendant face à celui dont il défend
les intérêts et j'ai toujours dit aux
gens vous savez si je veux convaincre le
juge du pont voilà de ma thèse il faut
d'abord que je puisse convaincre Thierry
Mozart de la thèse de Thierry Moselle
vous voyez voilà vous avez raccroché la
robe en 2019 allez-vous malgré tout
continu à défendre les villesmain alors
oui non c'est à dire je ne peux plus
maintenant j'ai pris ma retraite
effectivement fin 2019 je ne peux plus
maintenant aller chez un juge
d'instruction je ne peux plus dire à ce
juge voilà j'insiste les époux Villemin
montrez-moi votre dossier etc mais je
peux en revanche discuter avec mes
confrères de la défense notamment
Marie-Christine chastant et François
Saint-Pierre je peux discuter avec eux
mais Thierry comment peut-on défendre un
couple
dont on est aussi proche quand on est
parti prenante à ce point on dit souvent
qu'un médecin doit éviter de soigner ses
proches oui on le dit mais alors là
comme on dirait je le bon les choses
sont claires Villemin est innocent
Jean-Marie était jugé donc le problème
de l'avocat des avocats que nous sommes
consiste actuellement
à permettre l'identification et la
démonstration de l'implication
criminelle de ce dont nous pensons
qu'ils sont les coupables vous pourriez
vous résoudre à l'impunité de ce crime
sachant ce que vous savez je garderai je
garderai un goût de d'amertume de
tristesse et d'ailleurs je dans mon
livre je parle des parties civils qui
sont confrontés à l'échec de la justice
on vit mal on vit mal c'est je sais
peut-être quand même vous savez souvent
je compare l'avocat que je suis un
médecin de famille vous avez vous-même
parlé de médecins de famille je le
compare au médecin de famille et lorsque
le patient du médecin de famille
succonde je suppose que ce médecin est
infiniment troublé triste désemparé et
ben pour l'avocat lorsque sa mission
n'arrive pas à son terme au succès
escompté ça fait mal ça fait mal
j'aimerais vous laisser tirer le mot de
le mot de la fin c'est que
j'ai vécu passionnément ce métier
j'ai appris la richesse de l'être humain
sa complexité les l'ambivalence donc je
parlais tout à l'heure de l'être humain
ça m'a cette cohabitation du bien et du
mal chez l'être humain
ça m'a beaucoup troublé alors
est-ce que c'est un indice de la liberté
de l'être humain je n'en sais rien je
t'ai pas de lumière philosophique pour
un juger pour la come éclaire là-dessus
j'ai rencontré dans mon métier des gens
abjects écœurants et puis des gens
merveilleux sublimes des intéressés et
je pense si je devais résumer
l'avocat pénalisme je crois qu'il doit
être un homme bienveillant je crois
qu'il doit être un homme pondéré et
surtout surtout un homme libre et
indépendant d'esprit voilà à peu près ce
que je peux dire pour l'essentiel suite
à ces années ces 47 années vraiment et
je remercie le je sais pas le le bon
Dieu je sais pas où le ciel de m'avoir
donné cette opportunité de vivre cela
merci Thierry merci à vous